alors que l'om s'est qualifié pour la
finale de la coupe de la ligue son
équipe réserve est en difficulté depuis
le début de la saison
son objectif de remonter en division
supérieure la cfa s'éloigne de plus en
plus
bonne année sur votre question et puis
quand j'ai bien travaillé 36 olivier
civile après deux ans de blessures il
vient de rechausser les crampons
en gros ça fait deux ans des blessures
gmt sans qu'ils aient à la reprise
ironie du sort c'est au tour de nico de
se blesser
il attend avec angoisse le verdict
médical
après son but lors de son premier match
avec l'om j'étais surpris que du bonheur
jordan n'a plus rejoué avec l'équipe une
néanmoins il continue avec senna et
alexander à s'entraîner avec les pros
mais voilà mon objectif c'est de pouvoir
réussir à mort c'est un fait et ça passe
par le sacrifice à l'entraînement oger
vous croire pourquoi j'ai franchi un
palier mais le championnat de la réserve
reste une priorité pour tous de mauvais
résultat aurait de graves conséquences
pour leur avenir
à la mi temps du match entre nîmes
l'équipe est menée 1 0
égaliser
c'est un match de gala d'égaliser
et là
il faut égaliser
demain
il faut légaliser
perdu
ouais voilà perdu gros à 0 nîmes
la défaite face à nîmes brise tout
espoir de remontée en cfa ahmed aurait
préféré vivre une année plus
victorieuses avec ses jeunes partenaires
d'autant qu'il sait que c'est
certainement sa dernière saison dans les
coups durs et les moments de doute
ahmed peut compter sur sa famille il a
sept frères et soeurs
je veux perdre avoue comme on veut
perdre je boude
aujourd'hui je souris un peu je te j'ai
alors demandé si je reste un peu ma
chérie syrien après match après match et
durée et peut pas parler ch hausse après
match tout simplement rendez vous lundi
matin pour ses entraînements faire le
point tranquillement à tête reposée
verra ce qu'a été ce qui n'a pas été et
se mettre au boulot ont gagné ce faire
on va le faire des malwares je fais mes
quatre ses premiers mois super tout se
passe bien et du jour admet je me suis
retrouvé un matin pratiquement à +17 du
lit quoi chez les benjamins ça c'est la
septième fois que j'entends ce mouvement
fait assez clair c'était pas des moments
sympas mais bon voilà comme cette visite
à la cera heureusement que j'étais ici
j'étais ici un peu avec mes frères
soeurs et mes parents et mes moments
avoir mon infirmière principal sas et à
toute heure
n'importe où n'importe quel la journée
était là pour essayer de soulager un peu
les murs c'était douleur après pendant
trois mois
24 sur 24 mais moi c'est une bonne leçon
de vie et que ça va pas s'il faut venir
pour retrouver un peu de sérénité se
retrouver les pieds sur terre soit et
c'est sur un noyau c'est la vraie vie ce
noyau aujourd'hui sans ma famille je
n'aurais jamais fait ce que j'ai je suis
en train de faire revendu je n'aurais
jamais ce footballeur professionnel
parce qu'à un moment donné soit soutient
moralement ou ou la possibilité qui
t'aident pour accomplir ton truc en
bandelettes ya besoin ça besoins des
familles et c'est vrai que c'est dit
fissiles comme jeudi pour ceux qui n'ont
pas leurs familles je pense aux
étrangers africains qui viennent
c'est difficile parce que tu es seul
nico c'est olivier ça va les toits alors
ah ouais ça va c'est même passé
l'opération
c'est nico qui en ce moment aurait
besoin de ses proches le verdict est
tombé
comme pour olivier rupture des ligaments
croisés du genou docteur avec un minimum
de six mois de rééducation sa saison est
terminée il ne signera pas pro cette
année et à la fin ça m'étonnerait bien
se passer mais à priori le mignon c'est
un droit voiture vient ici on trouve pas
en charge et après un deuxième séjour
comme tu le sais à la fin de l'été à
l'entraînement en fait je me suis fait
ça tout seul
ces mobiles est resté bloqué sur un
changement de direction
mon genou il se développe des boîtes et
je sens un nouveau senti que quelque
chose n'allait pas je peux jouer un gros
coup on sait que ça a craqué
sur le coup ça m'a fait mal mais
trois minutes après j'étais bien être
banal on va pas trop denses renault
séparer spall ligaments croisés tout et
tout les bienvenus ce poster résume à ce
défi
cependant en fait il guérit pas on doit
le remplacer carrément et d'arracher
entendons sur la cuisse et leurs
employeurs en place et faire de trous et
en fait de vices et de
à la place de l'ancien galant qui est
rompu
vous
alors que l'équipe une est au sommet de
sa forme avec dix victoires consécutives
en championnat et sans ticket en poche
pour la finale de la coupe de la ligue
l'équipe réserve
au contraire est en difficulté la
défaite contre nîmes a lancé une
mauvaise série
le mois de mars ne se soit dès que par
des échecs
le doute s'installe l'équipe vacille à
présent ce n'est plus la montée en cfa
qui préoccupent les joueurs mais le
risque de relégation en division
inférieure pour tous ces joueurs là
descente en division d'honneur
risquerait de mettre un coup d'arrêt à
leur progression alors l'ambiance est
tendue d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui la
réserve rencontre monaco une des
meilleures équipes de ce championnat est
plus qu'important il semble jouer la
montée et nous la descente donc
donc s'il n'a pas enlevé pas de
résultats on se retrouve un th
quand même club comme l'om aurait fait
pas tellement ils sont surtout pas
surtout par l arrivée là or il faut
gagner pour se gagner reste neuf matches
sans gagner au moins quatre c'est
possible c'est possible on allait on a
les joueurs au et ses pièces c'est pas
suffisant pour le 8e forum expérience
les chaussettes et kitana un jour
et puis le couple à chaussettes il ne
croit pas que c'est le groupe que le
gala colonnes parce que d'obliger de
méthane va les fatiguer et la maîtrise
intérieur souple que tu fais là d'après
il y découper
on a pas trente-six la cop10 il avait il
ajouté
je récupère près que par messagerie
quand tu coupes je dois me
la mère de camille
on n'y arrive pas c'est trop court parce
que triaud sympa ta famille un jour un
jour un jour
comprendre le fond pas dans le ballon le
mettre au sol redoubler les passes
tranquillement d'accord il faut il faut
mais faire courir le ballon pas vous
compter avec le ballon il n'y a pas de
solution c'est faire preuve alors
s'appuyer là et on n'oublie pas ce n'est
pas la largeur des points de retard mais
pas se précipiter
d'accord elle 0 dans le ring futur il
faut chaud il fait chaud pour vous mais
pour eux c'est à celui qui va vouloir
plus
d'accord les gardes ya encore quinze
minutes quinté but encore une fois je
vous le dis les gars ils vont avoir plus
valable pour le mc oran il faudra
parcourir
m
jouer cette victoire permet à l'équipe
de se mettre momentanément à l'abri
d'une descente en division d'honneur
mais au delà du collectif olivier est
inquiet pour son avenir
l'année prochaine est très incertaine en
fin de deuxième année
il doit soit signé pro soit parti mais
après deux ans de blessures le club peut
à titre exceptionnel le prolonger d'une
année si je pense que j'ai pas récupéré
de mon niveau et qui comptent sur moi et
qui pense que je vais le récupérer et
même le surélever ils peuvent ils pas me
prolonger l'année quoi pour vraiment me
faire me permettre de récupérer mon
niveau et m'intégrer petit à petit
j'avais les pros est bon s'il se passe
ça c'est quand même c'est parce qu'on ne
peut pas arriver directement qu'on ne
peut pas arriver de deux ans de
blessures et signer pro à la fin de
l'année serait miraculeux même si c'est
exceptionnel et quand j'ai vu que de ça
ou alors sinon s'ils prennent la
décision de ne pas me garder
c'est qu'ils pensent que ben mais j'ai
pas récupérer le niveau alors qu'ils ne
voient pas faire une carrière à l'om
mais bon voilà on vit on vit l'instant
présent et le but est de tout donner au
présent coïncident pas avoir de regret
la victoire de l'équipe réserve et
peut-être de bonne augure pour l'om qui
joue ce soir sa finale de la coupe de la
ligue contre bordeaux
alexander et jordan ne figure pas sur la
feuille de match c'est des tribunes du
stade de france qui vivront cette
rencontre comme à ses habitudes
ahmed suit le match au foyer du club de
foot amateur de son quartier natal
18 ans 18 ans que l'om n'a pas remporté
le moindre titre
autant dire que la jeunesse marseillaise
n'a jamais connu son équipe a fait le
coup
alors ce soir la ville tremble hurle
croiser des doigts et invoque les
esprits jusqu'à enfermé l'équipe rivale
dans un paquet de chips superstition
quand tu nous tiens
à toi
ok
il faut
voir
ça
non
légaliser
l'égalité sociale
hélas
non
c'est plus ce qu'elle était
à
voilà
il a fallu tout cas pas là
la victoire des uns ne fait pas oublier
la défaite des autres
la lutte pour le maintien continue
l'efficacité de l'entraîneur michel
flosse est remise en cause l'olympique
de marseille vit une année unique ou
deux destinées opposés se croivent celle
de l'équipe une qui remporte après 18
ans de disette sa première coupe de la
ligue et s'envole vers les sauver du
championnat et celle de sa petite soeur
qui s'effondre et craint plus que jamais
une relégation en dh pour répondre à la
presse qui se délecte de cette situation
exceptionnelle les cours de media
training organisé par le club offre une
bonne préparation pour faire face à la
curiosité des journalistes
la première question est ce qu a pas un
problème avec cette réserve parce que
vous arrivez pas actuellement à
enchaîner les résultats
est ce que c'est un problème dans
l'équipe un prêt mais l'entraîneur non
l'équipe fonctionne très bien sauf que
je n'arrive pas à jouer ensemble et du
potentiel dans individuelle mais après
n'arrive pas à se trouver sur le terrain
et pouvoir gagner des matches mais sinon
le poteau c'est la faulx changer
l'entraîneur j'ai pas d'avis sur son
entraîneur c'est pas à moi de décider
s'il faut ce sujet l'entraîneur moi je
tiendra son contrat jusqu'au bout il
terminera la saison ce qui se passera en
fin de saison merci donc dans l'ensemble
bon je vous dis donc c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt satisfaisant quoi et vous avez vu
que déjà sur certaines questions vous
avez mis les pieds dans le plat
à certains moments que savoir des foyers
des réponses tout simple affaire est que
il ya aussi des tes sujets sur lesquels
vous n'avez pas à vous exprimer
parce que pour l'instant voilà et à des
questions vous avez pas y répondre quoi
sur l'avenir de michel flos sait même
pas y répondre quoi c'est pas à vous d'y
répondre à cette question là moi je
réponds pas à quoi c'est pas moi c'est
pas mon problème à moi je suis là pour
jouer points ok donc on travaillera là
dessus pour avoir des réponses claires
et précises quoi un hoquet gars aller
tout ça s'est fait de ces zones obscures
pas encore
dax tout ça elle accepte qu'ils vont
rester pas tout
ça commence à arriver là dure à gérer un
avenir pour
tapas des nasri tout un coin
malheureusement pour eux le mois d'avril
est une période sous haute tension pour
les jeunes c'est par simple courrier en
effet que l'om leurs annonces y
poursuivre ou non leur aventure au sein
du club
chaque matin c'est l' angoisse de la
lettre
pour ceux qui quittent le centre de
formation ce n'est pas toujours facile
de poursuivre sa carrière ailleurs
bruno anciens espoirs de l'om a quitté
le club à 24 ans puis il a évolué dans
d'autres équipes moins prestigieuses de
cfa2 et de division d'honneur il y a
deux ans il a décidé de se reconvertir
depuis il est gérant d'une boutique de
téléphonie au sein de l'om entre 15 et
24 ans il a vécu onze années onze mois
d'avril
notre lettre recommandée et qui nous
disait le contrat qu'on allait avoir
si on était prolongée ou pas ou voilà on
savait ça par lettre recommandée en fait
c'est la loi qui veut que
il faut qu'il nous prévienne je me
rappelle plus date mais il me semble que
c'etait c'est par là
avril mai on est fixé un autre sort dans
ce mot là donc c'est mam à chaque fois
que nous appeler que j'ai reçu la lettre
recommandée de l'om
qu'est ce que je fais ou l'ouvreur
tarbais n'en vois là dessus dit il faut
savoir quoi et puis voilà toutes les
années c'était mais bon la voilà sur
deux après quand en réserve comme sa
commission est actuellement puisqu'ils
font pas une superbe saison et ça fait
quelques années qu'ils sont en train de
galérer
je suis parent est difficile pour un con
et honnêtement je vois pas qui c'est qui
peut de cette génération-là passer
professionnel ça m'est difficile
donc si je me suis confiée à leur donner
c'est bien qu'ils se découragent pas
exact qu'ils aillent faire des systèmes
par droite à gauche
même dans les petits clubs de marseille
la fin d'année sonne l'heure des bilans
nico a rendez vous avec le directeur du
centre de formation
celui ci veut s'entretenir avec le
joueur sur cette année prématurément
avorter le bilan de la saison
elle est un résumé de tous les malheurs
que footballeur et il peut avoir dans sa
carrière déjà la blessure pas simple et
cumulé avec le fait que la première
partie de saison sportivement l'a pas
été très très intéressante avec petite
incompréhension électronique du catr
tout ça fait que tu as tu es très
rarement fait des match plein et quand
même quand une information c'est le but
ce début de jouer d'essayer de
progresser donc cumuler deux paramètres
pourraient dire que ça aura été une
année noire maintenant de ces
difficultés il faut francs sortir plus
fort je sais ça m'a poussé à réfléchir
réflexion que mène vers une paix j'ai
reçu comme je dois jouer peut-être que
je dois mettre plus d'un il peut faire
plus d'efforts sûr le terrain être plus
efficace
tout est travaillé sur mes défauts en
dehors des péripéties qui sont
importantes
ta blessure il faudrait pas que tu
gâches potentiel que tu as tous les
joueurs tous les joueurs et après
l'encadrement aussi nous tous à pnn tous
super du coup je trouve que c'est très
très important parce que ça nous fait
plaisir des fois
d'habitude on reçoit pas des messages
tout ça mais en ce moment où je me suis
blessé d'un coup tout le monde m'a
toujours j'ai reçu beaucoup de messages
et ça m'a beaucoup aidé tout le monde
est dans 10 ans et inquiète pas ça va ça
va aller pour sam ça m'a donné envie de
revenir
si je vois qu'il ya nos coéquipiers qui
croient en moi et qui me soutiennent ce
que ça veut dire que moi aussi je ne
craque croire en moi nico n'a pas le
moral au beau fixe mais son avenir n'est
pas remise en cause est en stage et la
première année il lui reste encore toute
la saison prochaine pour espérer signer
pro
après la défaite contre calvi le verdict
est sans appel
michel flos a été remercié franck passi
ancien joueur de l'om a été appelé pour
le remplacer et essayer de sauver
l'équipe
mission bien périlleuse à quatre
journées de la fin du championnat
aujourd'hui ils affrontent fréjus
apparemment je suis en retard
et j'espère le papa la manne avec lui le
plus proche
la cité retard c'est quoi ça dépote ça
n'est pas encore tranchée en retard
suisse a reçu si je suis en retard de 10
minutes je croise 1,50 euro ça passe
vite leurs mains
après ça que j'ai commencé le foot c'est
la première année que je joue le
maintien j'avais joué beaucoup la
pression jouera le maintien on n'a pas
trop râleur serait catastrophique de
descente en dh avec un centre de
formation
déjà pour le niveau nous allons
rencontrer des équipes amateurs sur des
terrains qui sont qui ne sont plus de
l'eau jusqu'au terrain de quartier et
c'est vrai que c'est pas de la
préformation
alors que l'équipe réserve joue son
avenir à chaque match l'équipe première
de l'om touche du doigt ce rêve tant
attendu
champion de france
j'ai tellement envie de la voir que
presque à l'intérieur on est terrorisée
de le manquer mais tous sont nés dans
cet esprit là ici c'est à dire comme on
n'en parle pas le prochain match contre
fréjus est capital s'ils perdent c'est
la descente en dh et une probable remise
en cause de l'avenir de certains joueurs
qui est un réservoir de joueurs qui vont
devenir pro
mais aussi c'est la possibilité pour
ceux qui forment pro2 d'essayer de faire
des matches pour avoir du temps de jeu
s'ils jouent à mâlain provenaient
joignez h il reste quatre matches à
l'équipe réserve pour se sortir de ce
mauvais pas il ne faudra concédé aucune
défaite
également fait leur vie et l'action
petropars près les journaux matters
quand j'arrêterai
alors les gars
le ballon les gars jouent depuis que tu
aimais plus ni avec les collègues si ça
c'est mon masque s'accomplit au couteau
je prie journée toujours là
pour montrer dès le premier quart
d'heure car épouse
dugas ok le prix du bois